IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> Sean: JOINING US TO REACT
TO ALL OF THIS, MICHELLE MALKIN.
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT, DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA.
MICHELLE, THERE IS SO MUCH HERE.
I WILL LET YOU TAKE IT.
I KNOW YOU'VE GOT A LOT TO OFFER
I KNOW YOU'VE GOT A LOT TO OFFE
OFFER.
>> THE FACT IS THE RESISTANCE
MEDIA IS SHOOTING BLANKS.
WHEN THEY ARE USING CROSS HAIRS
IMAGERY, THEY HAVE NO SELF
AWARENESS.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WENT
NUTS WITH SARAH PALIN OVER
CROSS HAIRS.
NOW YOU'VE GOT WHOOPI GOLDBERG
ESSENTIALLY ROOTING FOR RIOTS.
I RECALL A TIME BEFORE THE
ELECTIONS WHEN THE LEFT AND THE
LEFTISTS IN THE MEDIA LECTURED
AMERICA WHEN THEY WERE SO
CONFIDENT IT WAS GOING TO BE
HILLARY CLINTON THAT WE HAD TO
ACCEPT THE ELECTION RESULTS.
REMEMBER THIS?
WE COULDN'T HAVE ANY KIND OF
CIVIL UNREST.
WE NEEDED CIVIL ORDER.
NOW THEY ARE CHEERING FOR RIOTS.
AS A RESULT OF THEIR EMPTY,
EMPTY CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
REALITY.
IF YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH "THE
CAINE MUTINY," THE NOVEL, THE
CHARACTER ON A FISHING
EXPEDITION FOR STRAWBERRIES.
THAT IS ROBERT MUELLER.
>> Sean: THE COMPLICITY HERE
IS KEY BECAUSE THE MEDIA NOT
LOOKING AT THE FISA ABUSES, NOT
LOOKING AT HILLARY'S, WE KNOW
SHE COMMITTED FELONIES.
WE KNOW SHE WAS EXONERATED
WITHOUT INVESTIGATION.
WE KNOW SHE PAID FOR THE
DOSSIER.
WE KNOW THAT THE FISA JUDGES
WERE LIED TO, DR. GORKA.
THEIR FOCUS ON RUSSIA, STORMY,
KAREN, WHATEVER ELSE, THEY ARE
COMPLICIT IN ALL OF THIS.
THEY DON'T REPORT THE NEWS
ANYMORE.
THEY DON'T DO INVESTIGATIVE WORK
>> SEAN, I'M NOT SURE THEY
ACTUALLY DID.
WHAT DID WE SEE DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION?
OUTRAGEOUS SYCOPHANCY.
NOT ONE SMIDGEN OF CORRUPTION.
THEY TOWED THE LINE DESPITE FAST
AND FURIOUS, IRS, BENGHAZI, AND
NOW THEY ARE EXCITING, EXCITED
ABOUT LAWYER CLIENT PRIVILEGE
BEING BROKEN FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN AMERICAN HISTORY WITH
REGARDS TO A PRESIDENTIAL
LAWYER.
THEY LIVE IN A FEVER DREAM.
THEY CAN'T GET OVER WATERGATE
AND THEY ARE DESPERATE,
DESPERATE TO GET BACK TO THE
DAYS OF WATERGATE.
THE FACT IS THEY SEE THEIR
MISSION AS ONE THING, TO TAKE
DOWN A REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT.
THAT'S NOT THE JOB OF THE MEDIA.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY THINK THEY
ARE DOING.
THEY ARE DETACHED FROM REALITY
BECAUSE COMPARE THAT TO WHAT THE
AVERAGE PERSON OUTSIDE THE
BUBBLE IS LIVING THROUGH, AND
THEY ARE LOVING IT.
THE ECONOMY, ISIS, THE CRUSHING
OF ILLEGAL MIGRATION.
>> Sean: I THINK WE ARE THE
ONLY SHOW THAT HAS REPORTED ALL
OF THE GOOD NEWS.
I PUT MY LIST UP.
I WILL BRING IT BACK THIS WEEK.
>> I JUST CAME BACK FROM L.A.,
AND I AM MEETING WITH PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE FINALLY
ACTUALLY OPTIMISTIC THAT THEY
CAN GET SOME SANITY BACK INTO
THE PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC.
WHY?
THEY SEE A PRESIDENT TO HIS
BROKEN ALL THE RULES AND IS
BRINGING US BACK TO WHERE WE
SHOULD BE AS A NATION.
THAT IS CALIFORNIA.
THESE PEOPLE LIVE IN THEIR
COSSETED, KEVLAR COATED BUBBLE
AND THEY WILL NEVER UNDERSTAND
IT.
IT IS HATRED, PURE HATRED.
>> Sean: WHAT ADVICE DO YOU
GIVE THE PRESIDENT, MICHELLE?
HE'S HIS BEST ADVOCATE,
SPOKESPERSON, DEFENDER?
DOES HE GO TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
DOES HE LET HIS LAWYERS DO IT?
>> HE HAS ALWAYS TRUSTED HIS OWN
INSTINCTS.
CLEARLY THERE HAS BEEN A
HOUSECLEANING I THINK THAT WAS
IN ORDER.
AND HE IS JUST GOING TO LET
TRUMP BE TRUMP.
AS LONG AS HE HAS A DIRECT
CONDUIT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT.
HE KEEPS SPEAKING HIS MIND.
WHETHER IT'S IMPROMPTU WHERE HE
THROWS OUT THE TALKING POINTS
AND TALKS ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT IN THE MOMENT,
THE INVASION ON THE BORDER.
>> ONE THING FOR THE PRESIDENT,
WE NEED MORE SURROGATES.
HE'S THE BEST COMMUNICATOR BUT
ONE I WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE, IT
WAS SHOWN, ME, KELLYANNE AND